this is talk TV
[Music]
hey oh yay
oh yay
here we are on talk TV the [ __ ] in at
solo it's a place to be
should Matt Hancock be in Australia Fair
or promoting this constituent's welfare
so let's all hear your claps and cheers
to welcome our host the wonderful peers
God bless you all God Save the King
live from the [ __ ] Inn in Suffolk this
is Piers Morgan uncensored
well good evening from Gloria Suffolk
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored a new
location for the show tonight uh Matt
Hancock is of course the man who puts
the [ __ ] into Hancock so tonight I've
come to the [ __ ] in which just happens
to be Matt Hancock's local pub the
disgraced MP is of course 10 000 miles
away in Australia taking part in a
reality television show so far he's been
filmed eating camel penis cows anus and
a sheep's vagina apparently this is all
in the name of promoting dyslexia
awareness yeah right actually it's about
promoting himself and transferring a
four hundred thousand pound fee that's
why he's doing this and of course too as
he put it get forgiven
well here in little furlough the people
he's actually paid to represent in
Parliament are facing the same problems
as the rest of the country in much of
the world soaring inflation sky-high
energy bills stagnating wages a Health
Service crumbling much down to what he's
been doing at it in the last couple of
years today even prime minister Rishi
sunak condemned him saying MPS of all
parties should be busy fixing the
country and he's right and while
Hancock's squirms in the Australian
jungle humiliating himself yet again
it's worth remembering the record of the
Burke behind the smirk because this is
no laughing matter as health secretary
in the pandemic he sent thousands of
elderly patients from hospitals back to
their nursing homes without testing them
for covid a deadly Fiasco that led to
thousands of unnecessary deaths he was
forced out of his job after an affair
which broke not only his marriage vows
but also the lockdown rules that he
imposed on the rest of us with the dire
warning don't kill your Gram
the former landlord of this very Pub an
acquaintance of Hancock with no
experience of producing medical
equipment was dragged into the
controversy when it was revealed he'd
been given a contract worth 40 million
pounds for covid supplies
Hancock had been photographed pulling a
pipe behind this very bar he even had a
picture of his Pub on his office wall
truly as I said at the start he's a man
who puts the [ __ ] into the [ __ ] in well
campaigners today feel a banner across
the jungle Campsite in Australia that
read kovid bereaved say get me out of
here and they're right aren't they Matt
Hancock shouldn't be taking part in I'm
a celebrity it's not a celebrity he's
ashamed politician who calls thousands
of deaths with his decision-making and
who at the resigning disgrace just a few
months ago it shouldn't be cashing in on
all this with either his jungle
appearance or his forthcoming book of
Diaries the only thing that you're doing
in his Diaries is handing them over to
any inquiry that goes on into covid-19
and why the UK had the highest death
toll in terms of people who died in the
whole of Europe and above all you should
be listening to the people sitting right
here tonight about the very real
problems they face at the heart of an
MP's work far away from the Gilded Halls
of Westminster is a constituency surgery
it's where MPS meet the people they work
for in the place they call home
one-on-one so they can understand their
lives well Hancock can't be bothered
with that he'd rather be eating kangaroo
testicles 10 000 miles away so I've
moved in I'm going to do his surgery for
him I'm going to meet his constituents
hear their anger hear their problems and
maybe even try and help them and I'm
doing it in the [ __ ] in could there be a
more appropriately titled pup
so let's get started I'm joined now by
the landlord of the [ __ ] in John Byers
John yeah please great to see you thank
you very much for hosting us you're not
the infamous landlord no no I should say
for legal reasons was not established
you've done anything wrong but obviously
he was a an acquaintance of Matt Hancock
from this Pub and ends up with this
contract
what is the mood in this part of West
Suffolk about the MP who's paid 84 000
pounds a year to represent the people
here gallivanting in this reality show
in Australia not doing his job yes I
think I mean there are mixed views but I
think the majority of people that I've
spoken to who are aggrieved at the fact
that he's well hasn't been doing it what
he should be doing I think so I mean if
this was my mp I'll be outraged so where
are you there's a cost of living crisis
there's a war raising in Europe yeah
there's really serious stuff happening
and he's just making a fool of himself
in a jungle with all these be-less
celebrities not doing what he should be
doing for the people of little furlough
yes yeah I mean I'm I'm being hit with
the uh with the energy crisis
um I know there is a now a business cap
on on energy but it's what impact does
it add on you and it's well it doesn't
even touch the sides the uh the the help
I get for the government so to be honest
it it could be a fact of whether whether
this Pub continues come the end of the
year it could really not it couldn't
survive the year yeah exactly it's such
a power hungry um business running apart
Hancock was here would you be able to
see him and express your concern about
that I would like to speak to him about
it but he can't right no I can't you see
that to me cuts to the very heart of
this you should be able to have that
conversation with your MP that's what
he's paid to do that's what he was
elected to do yeah and there's you
facing potentially going under yeah
losing a pub that I imagine you love yes
I do in an area that it's a it's a
beautiful country but I grew up in a pub
so I have a great Affinity with pubs
it's a lovely little Country Pub and a
lovely meal that you cooked for me
earlier and the idea that you may lose
all this and that the person who should
be able to help you who's the Member of
Parliament for West Southern is doing
what he's doing that sticks in my Gully
and I'm not you yeah exactly yeah no I
am yeah I am fairly aggrieved at it I
must admit there's
not necessarily just him I think a lot
of MPS haven't haven't been doing what
they what they should have been doing
for quite a long time now so um yeah I
think there are still quite a few
problems with the UK at the moment well
John I appreciate you having us tonight
we're going to meet a few more people
now so if the cameras follow me
and thank you to all my guests who join
me some of them will have very serious
Stories We want to talk about a bit
later in the program
but joining me now two of Hancock's
constituents Gary Butcher and ampatient
so Gary let me start with you
that story just immediately has annoyed
me yes but the fact that this Pub that
landlord may go under as his MP is
eating kangaroo testicles that that
angers me does it anger you it does yes
what do you make of all this
I think it's disgusting it's completely
disgusting I think the bloke should be
deselected
the money is getting from appearing in
the jungle should be donated to charity
we should have proof it's donated to
charity
and his salary that is still commanding
through being an MP it that should be
stopped I imagine completely imagine I
couldn't get away with it what would you
do for a living train driver you're a
train driver if you just didn't turn up
for six weeks I'd get paid you wouldn't
get paid right why should a member of
parliament be able to do this exactly
it's outrageous isn't it what's the
difference
you have a particular uh complaint at
the moment about inability to see a
dentist they're all private yes what are
you doing about that I'm going back to
uh Bishop no sorry sir from Warden when
my original dentist not on registered
with I can't get a dentist anywhere near
here several boards how far away
um probably 20 miles 20 miles to get to
go and see a dentist now if your MP was
here and having surgeries with the
constituents you could raise that with
it I've already raised it with him but
he won't answer the emails he wouldn't
answer your emails is that right yes
yeah so even when he's here he's useless
completely do you think he should have
gone after the the pandemic the way he
handled it and then particularly the way
he had to leave government for breaking
his own rules
the pandemic is very difficult it's
something no one's experienced before
you give them a bit of a pass a slight
pass but what about breaking is that
right his own rules is disgusting the
right to go but should he be allowed now
to do a book and profit from it go into
a TV show and profit from now why
and you've voted conservative for 50
years yes but now you're not going to
again the last two times I haven't no
um
I just I don't know who I'm going to
vote for you've got Rhys smog at the
back of this conservatives you've got
clubbing types at the back of the labels
when did you last vote Conservative then
oh
eight years ago all right so you've been
turned off by them for a while yeah why
the MPS of today just don't come up to
what they used to be
the state of the country today is
unbelievable I was a war baby and lived
through 10 years of rationing
and saw the country come up and up and
up and now we're just going down and
Down and Down You're The Treasure of the
Village Hall I think aren't you so you
have a good Community role here and you
take care of people in the in the
community what do you feel about your MP
just doing what he's doing and not
actually doing his job I can't believe
it
he's needed here
charity begins in his constituency
I mean the only charity he's really
certainly knows himself I'm not how to
mentioned dyslexia or something heard on
there much at all that's not why he's
there we all know that he's there
because he wants forgiveness and he
wants us to all say it none of this
matters and here's a load of money
yeah tell that to people who are trying
to heat their houses neat how tough is
it at the moment for people do you think
well around here at the moment it's not
showing but there's lots of places in
the area that are probably suffering I
mean are there people who are literally
making a choice between eating and
heating I've read about this but is that
happening
I don't know at the moment and at the
moment we are trying to get
um warmth and heat to people in the
village hall the wi are going to put
events on and
have warm food and
if because at the moment I have to say
it's not too cold yet you know it's not
it really isn't but it could turn quite
quickly we're heading towards December
then January February what's going to
happen here to people who don't have
much money and can't afford the heating
bills well
as I say the wi are going to put various
fence on
and the
Village Hall is very warm
and
hopefully there will be somewhere for
them to go I mean it's incredible that
has to happen what's your message to
Matt Hancock if he was watching us he's
not because he's got no access to
television but if he did what would you
say to him
I wouldn't vote for him again what would
you say to him about what he's done his
dereliction of Duty
it's just disgusting he's that's not
what he's he's not paid to go out to the
Jungle he's paid to be here the amount
of holidays that MPS have Boris Johnson
was away when he should have been in
Parliament his dad's over there you can
take it out on him get used to it yes
these down breaks are always real
and then my tan Cox he's supposed to be
here well he is and Gary what would your
message to him be if you wanted to talk
to him don't show your face we don't
want you stay in Australia yeah you
think you should be deselected as an MP
I certainly do you do yeah because that
can happen yeah I think it should and do
you think that's the mood of most people
most people I speak to yes most friends
of yours feel the same yeah if it wasn't
for people like and Evan the wi eating
the village hole there are going to be
people who are welcome now
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me well let's go now to another
part of the pub you'll be unsurprised to
hear my next three guests are already
drinking uh they are of course uh the
former I'm a celebrity contestant
Stanley Johnson former conservative
Minister Ann Whitaker another former I'm
a celebrity contestant Christine
Hamilton welcome what a starry pack we
have in the [ __ ] in tonight and yes you
just heard those two just local
constituents they're regular people
they're not celebrities they're not
being paid vast sums of money to go to a
jungle because I don't qualify to better
do that but their anger is palpable and
they're concerned about what may happen
to people here is palpable well I've
said throughout that he should not be in
the jungle and that no mp uh should take
that sort of extensive time off just for
a reality show I mean it's not even
recess it's session
um you know quite apart from the
constituents which you've highlighted
he's not voting he's not you know so
um I've always said that he should not
be there and I've used the phrase that
you used dereliction of Duty having said
that I've been rather surprised uh at
the way he's performed in the jungle and
the way that the campmates are now
starting to fall and that does surprise
me well they're really to me it's making
me vomit because they're all like
warming to him so this porn acts right
there's this guy you know doing all the
challenges eating all the bugs all this
kind of thing Whoopi do and they're all
like high-fiving in and they're all you
know cheering that's not how they
started off and that is why I'm actually
quite intrigued by what is going on in
that jungle because they started off
very very well it's human nature because
they're all look Christy they're all
hungry they're all a team you have to
work together they're probably quite
pleased he's not doing so badly in the
challenges he brings back food for them
they're delighted because as you say
they're getting without him doing well
in the challenge and let's be fair to
Matt Hancock for the moment if you can
just bear with me he has done
brilliantly on those challenges he has
done every single one whether it's
eating or something interesting but he
has done I can't watch it I start
watching because I actually feel so
incense so when I think back to friends
of mine who had to say goodbye to their
mothers
because the covid virus had ripped
through a care home because nobody had
been tested when they got sent back from
hospitals I think of Matt Hancock and it
makes me so angry why all I was just
trying to say that he has done those
trials well which is one reason why his
campmates are feeling good towards him
because he's putting food in their
stomach so you've had politics in your
veins since you were younger far too
long right so what do you make of the
the principle I think it's important
Member of Parliament doing this he
absolutely he should not be there and
the people who he is insulting most of
all are the people sitting in this club
his constituents secondly he is
insulting the taxpayer who is paying him
very most people think that what is it
85 000 a year is a pretty good salary
he's taking all that while he's there
and the other people that he is
insulting are the people who really
suffered during covid he simply should
not be there Stanley you're rightful
you're a world expert and defending so
off you go yeah I am getting the
impression tonight that there is a
certain feeling that they're not
breaking on on Matt Hancock I noticed
that you you've taken that you're rather
strongly yes
I tell you I'm going to take a slightly
different view I I'm as I'm just
confessed I've actually known my Mad
Hatter for a while
we were at the same
college at the same University they're
not actually the same time I was at
Exeter College he was there too Oxford
but he was there about you know 50 years
after me that said I have known him and
I've always been extremely impressed by
him as a child I first met him by the
way when he was just in the business of
losing 14 kilos why was he losing 14
kilos so he could ride a horse in a new
market race
and give the winnings to the disabled
jockeys fund right witchy Jolly world
did now that to me exemplifies the man
that all this idea
I want to go on I want to go on the idea
that you can only serve your
constituents by being present in your
constituency that is garbage it is total
garbage
let me explain there's a man there who
can't see a dentist
as a woman treasurer
do you want me to say something
okay let me answer the way he is helping
his constituents I know there's a highly
literate consequency but there will
nonetheless be some constituency here
who are maybe uh dyslexic and by the way
that's a very prevalent disease if it is
a disease there are certainly people
here who would like to get their
children into the Cambridge hospitals
and he's about he has been working hard
as
it's all about him wanting forgiveness
from the public anyway look I've got to
leave it there when I come back to the
pack a little later when we'll hear more
stories and I want to see Stanley if any
part of it changes your mind we'll be
back from the [ __ ] in after the break
foreign
about the world's most famous footballer
now it's his turn
start by asking why are you doing this
interview I think it's the time
to say something 19 minutes with
Cristiano Ronaldo Cristiano an exclusive
that's rocked the sports world
Wednesday and Thursday nights at 8pm
only on Piers Morgan uncensored
[Music]
welcome back to Matt Hancock's local pub
appropriately named the [ __ ] Inn I'm
here with some of his constituents and
we're pondering what he's doing in
Australia rather than doing his job here
let's remind ourselves of his
performance as our health secretary in
the pandemic
I'm really struck by the fact that you
feel incensed that we're not thanking
you enough for your handling of this
pandemic I was asking for that you
didn't save lives did you we've got 130
000 deaths the worst death toll in
Europe we have one of the worst death
rates in the world so I just don't know
why I should be thanking you I committed
to delivering that testing for people
going from hospital into Care Homes when
we could do it I then went away and
built the testing capacity for all sorts
of reasons and all sorts of uses
including this one and then delivered on
the commitment that I made do you know
what it is actually
what I'm really looking for is a bit of
forgiveness
well joining me now is Julie Goodwin
whose husband sadly died from covid
local resident and reform candidate
Edmund Fordham his family had to visit
his mother-in-law and threw a window
during the pandemic and local resident
Emily Jackson whose grandfather died
from coast to three people who've all
had first-hand experience of this awful
virus and this terrible pandemic let me
start with you Julie you don't actually
come from around here when you heard
about this you you contacted us and you
wanted to come all the way down from
Nottingham where you live to have your
say about Matt Hancock why did you feel
so determined to do that
well uh I just can't believe that he's
in there you know when there's a cost to
live in Christ that's going on it should
be here for his con constituents
your husband a child he was a paramedic
yeah and he was just 61 when he got
covered and he died and I in fact read
out his name on Good Morning Britain
yeah that's when you heard about what we
were doing here you that was the
connection that we had I remember doing
that as part of a number of care and
health workers who died
um I presume that like most people whose
loved ones died in the pandemic very few
people could be at the funeral
now we could only have 15 and we were
one of lucky ones and you remain the
lockdown rules to do that of course well
we was locked in he left a special needs
daughter and a son and I couldn't come
out the house
and when I could come out we had to
organize all his funeral on the front
garden
but you obeyed all the rules I did or
too scared to do anything else so when
you heard Matt Hancock who told you you
know your grandmother can die of all the
adverts if you don't take this seriously
do the rules when he heard he'd broken
the rules himself with his affair
how did that make you feel terrible
absolutely terrible one rule for him
exactly yeah one rule for him and one
for everybody else such as old while
herds suffered bereavement
we didn't matter to him
it's all I mean Germany Jackson you had
a similar thing with your grandfather
told me about that he was 101 when he
got covered and you weren't able to to
be where you wanted to be no we weren't
um my granddad was in a care home
um and we obviously we all had to stay
away and we weren't able to visit
um we were one of the lucky ones really
because he did he had a downstairs room
so we were able to see him sorry through
the um glass window so but so you could
just see him just every day just giving
up
um during the lockdown
um and
yeah Granddad sadly passed away and you
feel as a family that because you
weren't able to see him in the last
period of his life that actually
loneliness was a contributing fact I
believe yeah um Granddad I we believe
that as a family
um loneliness killed Granddad because
um his family were everything to him and
we were his life and without us he
couldn't understand he didn't have you
know he was able to walk he fully
understood what was happening but he
didn't understand the pandemic so what
do you feel about Matt Hancock I think
you've got a slightly less hostile view
of it why
because I believe in second chances
um because I believe that people can
make huge huge mistakes but I also
believe in
in forgiving
um I think my granddad always taught us
not to hold a grudge Pierce and that if
I'm gonna hold that hatred and that
anger to him it's it I'm going to be
bitter and I'm going to be angry and
that's a waste of energy
so I mean my anger of him is more not
that I don't think he deserves to have a
life after all this but he's not been
held accountable by any public inquiry
no no but he wants a health secretary
yep he did end up being five of breaking
his own rules and all these things when
you add up the charge sheet it's pretty
bad and we've not had an inquiry yet
into this so him profiting so greatly
from what's gone down I find distaithful
that's my argument with it it's more the
timing and what he's doing let me bring
in Dr Urban Fordham you're the reform UK
candidate for West suffer what do you
think about the MP doing what he's doing
well I think you know you've said it
other people have said it already it
goes to the heart of uh our system of
government that all every one of us gets
to elect a member of parliament to uh go
and represent us in the Palace of
Westminster and uh I do actually think
it's rather important that they're
around to do their job I mean I agree
with you on this and uh that's the
fundamental thing issues no matter what
your politics are right what are the big
issues around here which you should be
really dealing with well the one daily
basis okay so I'll give you an example
because the thing I have got my teeth
stuck into uh is the issue of this um
humongous solar farm complex that's uh
straddling West Suffolk and uh Southeast
Cambridge are just north of Newmarket
and uh it's going to be the size of New
Market the next thing put together and
it produces what in my opinion as a
physicist as an engineer is completely
piffling amount of of solar energy so
you're trying to sell them I'm trying to
stop it and Matt has said he's against
it both of the MPS involved in both
constituencies have said they're against
it he's headed up a protest March
against this solar farm and what's your
fear now so what but well let me tell
you this piece because what Wendy's
story broke I was actually engaged in
the opening session of the um public
examination into this uh this solar farm
proposal I was you know bending my
brains out going all over those are
these legal documents and listening
carefully to
um uh the uh the arguments and putting
in my uh putting in my own opinions and
uh where's Matt Hancock I get that you
know I get my phone going when I'm
trying to concentrate on this stuff and
the story's broken that he's in
Australia I completely I wouldn't
believe what I would say it's insane I
mean Julia you win the more stories I
hear like this down here we've heard a
lot before we even selected who we
talked to many many more but all these
stories really I think are illustrative
of how bad this is and it's not because
I totally get where you come from about
second chances I believe in that
Everyone's entitled to Redemption but to
be paid hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of pounds to go and humiliate
himself on television across in
Australia when things are so bad for so
many people in so many parts of the
country I just find disgraceful
it is disgraceful
because these people are going to choose
between eating and putting the eating on
right and that's how bad it is
I do yeah I'll put my end yeah I'm
hearing it down here as well there's a
lot
would you ever vote for someone like
Matt Hancock no no because my husband
would you pierce this is happening
throughout the country though this is
not just here the people I believe the
union people are doing this okay I get
that but what are the MPS doing that are
actually in their areas what are they
doing well at least there's people
starving there's people not having it
they're meeting their questions right I
mean what are they doing
it is actually and they should be voting
meeting your constituents hearing their
concerns acting on it and voting in
Parliament he's not doing any of these
things
but what are they doing that
admire your forgiving nature I'd be less
forgiving in your position with what
happened with you and your grandfather
final question quickly Dr Fordham are
you going to try and stop Matt Hancock
get him deselected you're gonna push for
that well whether he's deselected or not
he's actually up to his party what I've
done this afternoon is launched on
change.org a petition saying recall Matt
Hancock which you know any constituent
in West Suffolk is more than welcome to
sign and really what ought to be
happening is you know deselection that's
up to his own party
is is that we ought to have a
resignation and a by-election and then
the voters of West Suffolk can choose
whomsoever they please
thank you very much indeed Julie thank
you very much indeed for coming all the
way from Nottingham and uh Evan thank
you very much today we're lost more from
the increasingly annoyed talk in after
the break
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we shall discuss a former minister
is here celeb or someone sinister
could not become king of the jungle or
will it be another bungle God Save the
King
well welcome back to the cooking Matt
Hancock's uh regular Pub when he's not
eating kangaroo testicles 10 000 miles
away of course I'm with Matt Hancock's
constituents the ones he's not seeing at
the moment because he's trousering
hundreds of thousands of pounds to do
what he's doing in that jungle but there
is a cost living crisis NHS on his knees
and where's their MP he's doing this
the person there want to see fist
tentacles of Terror is
slurry just pulled on the head come on
slippery little suckers
horrible I've changed this moment how is
his friends with distinct crew oh no
that is disgusting
oh that's not nice but it's become part
of my morning routine you know you get
up you brush your teeth have a shave do
a trial go back for lunch
well joining me now a conservative
Council level where Suffolk in Holden
local residents Sarah diath and Martin
Williams thank you all for joining me I
can't even watch it anymore because to
me it just sticks in my gullet too much
and let me say to you uh councilor
holder I don't care that he's
conservative I wouldn't care what his
party is to me it's not about party they
happen to be the party of government
when the pandemic hit Matt Hancock
happened to be the health secretary I'd
judge him on his actions in a pandemic I
don't care that he's a conservative only
against him for being a conservative you
are a conservative what is your view of
it well as you say I'm a conservative my
view when it all came out on the
television
um
I was horrified that our health Minister
could deceive the country for so long
wagging his finger as you said don't
kill my granny do all these restrictions
you'll be fine you know it was daily for
months
and then suddenly we find that doesn't
mean anything to him he can do what he
likes I think that's supposed to
hypocrisy of what he did absolutely now
I wrote
immediately to him on email his
parliamentary address but more
importantly to the West Suffolk
conservative Association what were you
saying I was saying this is appalling
and we should start the process to get
him deselected right so he went as he
went as a government cabinet minister
but you want him this this is an MP gone
gone because he's and now now he's
deserting his constituents to do what
he's doing even more so I imagine well
yeah and the same Association that
circled the wagons round in wrote back
to me and said you know
we've forgiven him you know we've
accepted his heartfelt apology for God's
sake and
um he's back in the fall
did we the members of that Association
get a vote no of course my email was
full of Aya from members of that and
more so since he's gone into Australia
in the jungle I haven't no actually not
I think everybody has thrown their hands
up in horror and the conservative
Association issued a letter saying how
disappointed yeah but that's not enough
is it again Sarah dear you have a 10
year old boy he's he's special
educational needs and there's an issue
in this area which means at the moment
he's not getting what he should be
getting and your MP that you could be
taking it up with is in Australia what
do you feel
disappointed it's shameful
he wants forgiveness and
he thought he'd go on TV to try and get
it
I mean I don't care that he gets
forgiven I want to do his job you know
you get forgiveness actually by doing
your job properly then people may look
more fondly on absolutely doing what
he's doing in this jungle for massive
amounts of money in a cost of living
crisis when your boy isn't getting the
help he needs because we're Suffolk
Council haven't got the funding they
need
to move this process ahead my boy is
waiting for an ehcp he's waiting for a
diagnosis but there's families out there
that are suffering that have been
waiting years have you written Diagon I
haven't no would you be potentially
going to see him if he was here if it
was here of course I would absolutely
yeah but what I'm what I want to try and
get across is that there's families out
there that children haven't got places
in schools or they're being given ehcps
educational health care plans and
they're not being stuck to it's not even
worth the paper it's written on
so what would your message be to him if
you could see it no
no donate the money that you earned from
what you're doing
and help kids in the flipping vicinity
that need it like your boy like my boy
yeah like my boy we'll try and get some
help for you okay we'll try and do the
job he should do absolutely that's why I
wanted to meet people like you to say
look if he won't do it yeah we'll try
and do it okay we'll take a look all
right Martin you're a local resident
what do you make of all this
um well I've actually been a very vocal
supporter of Matt um over the last two
or three years through the pandemic
um I even bumped into him once and
thanked him for his efforts not
performance his efforts
um throughout that time
um this whole jungle thing I completely
disagree with
um he should be locally Stone where
where he should be to meet consist
constituents
um we've got a local issue in Newmarket
at the moment where buses have been
canceled the local
um Stagecoach company have have cut all
the roots to Cambridge and buries in
Edmonds and it's causing real hardship
for people who want to get the hospital
he should be dealing with it yes um he
did to be fair to him he did mention it
and come out against the fact that we're
being cut but of course all that's
formed by the wayside since he's I mean
I get the people people who say you know
we've got to move on from the pandemic
and I don't actually believe that Matt
Hancock deliberately tried to kill
people yeah I think he made
catastrophically bad errors of judgment
I don't think he did it deliberately
knowing what would happen but he did
make terrible decisions in the first
phase of that pandemic which cost a lot
of lives and it's incredibly serious
when that happens then he has to lose
his job for breaking his own rules which
I think most people found disgusting and
now he's profiting from all this by
deserting his constituents and that's my
real problem is that he's deserting the
constituents when they most need him
constituents like they have there well
it's as I say with the buses is the
local issue but with the broader cost of
living Sarah I'm sorry Sarah dear
my apologies again this very exotic name
suddenly the broader cost of living um
crisis I mean I'm on a relatively low
income I'm working six days a week at
the moment to make ends meet
um you know and a lot of people in that
situation as it goes on with mortgage
rates going up it's gonna it's gonna
[ __ ] a lot of people this is what
matters to us at the moment if you run
out of tolerance for Matt Hancock run
out of forgiveness
um
I wouldn't say that but I judge I judged
the situation as it as it happens so I'm
judging this jungle thing in in
isolation from I'm also you're a media
verdict on him well he he shouldn't be
there embarrassing isn't it yeah MP
doing this eating kangaroo testicles I
mean I've never seen the program I
haven't been watching it since he's been
in but you know it does it's not
particularly edifying is it really thank
you to all of you I hope we get you some
action maybe you could help with that
actually no I think about it can just do
a bit more of a shift thank you all very
much indeed we appreciate it lots more
from the [ __ ] in after the brain killing
reaction from my packaging see if
Stanley Johnson has changed his mind
when he's been hearing some of these
stories it's a tough nut to crack we'll
find out he's cracked after the break
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
live from the [ __ ] Inn in Little Thurlow
which is the constituency of Matt
Hancock who's in Australia deserting his
duty as a member of parliamentary course
to take part in Despicable embarrassing
humiliating trials uh I want to come
back to my pack here so let me ask you
Stanley I've got another VT every what
is it let's play it
[Applause]
I can imagine that this hasn't gone down
well it sticks out like a sore thumbnail
in so few ways in which
politicians can show that we're human
beings
I can't help but think
[Music]
what I'm really looking for is a bit of
forgiveness
that's what I'm really looking for hey
oh my God I nearly cried then
oh go be brilliant Matt Hancock is our
leader words that nobody in Britain ever
thought that they would hear oh that's
comfortable
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean I'm sorry I just makes me vomit
listening to him do that celebrating
being treated like some sort of hero
Christine I'm I just this to me great
I've seen a lot of people on Twitter by
the way and other social media platforms
getting increasingly angry there are
others that are warming to him falling
for this act but there are many many
people where this they're really saying
what is he doing in there well this he
just said it on on that clip that this
is a good way to show people that uh
politicians are normal people there are
a million and one ways to show that
politicians are normal people and you do
that in your constituency you do that
here you do it in all sorts of ways in
Westminster you do not have to go to the
other side of the world and be paid
allegedly four hundred thousand pounds
and how often do politicians if they're
in the constituency have a surgery with
their opposition most most will do it
weekly
um in some very big rural constituencies
they'll do it fortnightly but if you
don't quite get the pressure but you
would hear this kind of stories I've
been hearing tonight yeah but can I just
say one thing probably and Christine
will know this because she worked for
Neil Hamilton uh the um about nine out
of every 10 cases are actually handled
by the staff because they know what to
do and the MP comes in when the clout is
needed right so it doesn't but that
doesn't change anything that's not I
understand I haven't said that that
makes it right I hadn't said that and I
don't want to be portrayed as having
said that but I'm saying that when
you're portraying this picture of great
neglect and that the constituents can't
get anything done they can in most cases
all right because members of staff can
use the name of the mpa you're quite
right so it's Michael is my answer would
be we don't need an MP then so foreign
good point
MP does not have to be in his
constituency to do his job all the time
they should be Stanley no let me finish
on this one there are big jobs and
they're important jobs which don't
necessarily have to be done in the
constituency there are big issues are
you doing any job he is he is what's he
doing I can tell you what he's doing I'm
going to repeat it
that's what he's doing
look the constituents if you've just
said and Will Survive very well without
without a Matt Hancock being there what
is important
on December
no no no listen listen to something
factual on December the 2nd Parliament
is taking the second reading of the
detection on special teacher training
bill now Matt Hancock has managed to
bring that to parliament's table on
December the 2nd for the second reading
is brilliant that's right it's a private
member
benef beneficial to him on December the
second is that everybody will realize
this is an absolutely debunkable it's
yours pointed out there for one out of
four young children suffer from dyslexia
there's a clearly he may not even be
here
well it hasn't I mean he says he's going
in there to raise awareness
all right we are talking about it now
and we probably wouldn't be but that is
not why he's doing that that is so
disingenuous he's doing it for the money
and he wants to try and rehabilitate
himself and it is absolutely disgraceful
that he is not here no
um that's not true and what happens if
on December Matt Hancock's career as a
charity worker for the last 20 years and
I can say look it is of excellent
Excellence
please answer that very three basic
questions Stanley on December the 2nd if
he's still in the jungle how is he going
to promote that I'm not going to be in
the jungle on December yeah and he will
be back in Parliament wearing the Laurel
crown of okay of the winner
absolute rubbish I'm going to leave with
that Stanley as ever you managed to
almost try and defend the indefensible
nature luckily you were held to account
by these two very admirably oh let's go
back and talks
okay so I've bought the wrong card so
that's I knew at some stage I'd drop a
clanger and there it is so there we are
so I'm joined by two more constituents
welcome to you welcome to you so Sean
O'Connell and Michael pitcher Sean yeah
let me start with you you working I
think Waste Management yes is that right
you've heard this defense from Stanley
Johnson that actually he does some good
things it doesn't need to be here for
most of it what do you think I think as
a constituent empty MP's been decidedly
Anonymous for a whole of his tenure I do
appreciate he had a ministerial position
what qualifications you had to be a
minister for that position is uh
debatable PPE do you forgive him he
wants forgiveness you're not going to
get it by going on a television program
and try us within 400k really well I
don't think so I'm looking for my
amazement some people are beginning to
quote warm to him no not really
um it's not the format for that you
should be in his constituents and you've
got a particular thing about local buses
I think yeah well the buses are a bit of
an issue in the market but there are
particularly
um challenging areas in his constituency
that could do with his death he should
be getting on with sorting you I risk
you had to shield for three months no
outdoor space horrendous experience for
you when you saw not just Matt Hancock
but Dominic Cummings breaking the rules
Boris Johnson and all his number 10
staff getting fined by the police and so
on what did that make you feel given
what you had to go through
my house backed onto an old people's
home and I've witnessed body bags being
brought out
surrounded by people in hazmat suits
that really brings the the situation
home and what they did was Despicable
breaking their own rules for their own
gratitude I think they are answerable
and going into the jungle is not the
right way
um
completely he's asking for forgiveness
which implies that he knows he's done
something wrong right but I know that
when the inquiry comes he will dig his
heels in and he will defend his but he
will have already profited massively
completely from the infamy of being in
my opinion a terrible Health secretary
and then an absolutely shameful cabinet
minister Court breaking his own rule is
he shouldn't be allowed to profit from
moving into a celebrity status on the
back of being one of the worst Health
Center people literally dying correct
correct I mean to me it's absolutely
shameful thank you both of you I
appreciate it I want to come back to my
extremely uh I gotta say animated and
engaged audience tonight all local
constituents here
um what do you make of this let me just
just show off hands anybody here feel
that Matt Hancock's done a good job and
should keep his job as an MP
I mean literally two hand three hands
three hands
if you had a chance to vote on I'm a
celebrity for him to be king of the
jungle who would vote for him to be king
of the jungle
I've watched it one one hand you haven't
watched it okay but everybody one hand
would vote for him to be king of the
jungle and I guess the most crucial
question then is given this clearly most
people here are against Matt Hancock
have probably share a lot of My Views
about this if that is the case then you
don't have to wait till there's another
election you can deselect it it has to
be driven by its own party but he could
be deselected show me your hands here
who would like to see him removed as an
MP through deselection
I mean most hands here I'd say at least
two-thirds maybe three quarters
right and that's entirely true thank you
very much for joining me so there the
people have spoken from this part of
West Suffolk which is Matt Hancock's
constituency and they've spoken with
their hands Hancock come back and face
the Judgment whatever you're up to
tonight keep it unscented I'm gonna get
a pint of [ __ ] in the [ __ ] in thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]